Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Conway: PHOOZY is the world's
first thermal capsule.
It's like a space suit
for your phone.
You guys are my heroes.
Maxfield: Who wants
the soon‐to‐be‐most‐successful
"Shark Tank" product ever?
Ugh!
Tired of grabbing
germy door handles?
Which of you is ready
to fix this door‐handle dilemma?
The retailer that
rolls this out first
is going to own
the front porch.
What are your sales?
$7 million in sales.
What?!
You're living
the inventor's dream.
I want to own 51%.
‐I think that's a garbage offer.
‐Screw you.
I've got to go
live with myself
when I walk out of here.
Walk away.
That's how you do a deal.
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a simple product
designed to avoid germs.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Mike Sewell.
I'm from Springfield, Missouri,
and I'm here today on behalf
of my two business partners.
We are seeking $300,000
for a 3% stake in our company...
Ooh!
...StepNpull.
Whoa!
‐Whoa!
‐Wow!
Tired of grabbing
germy door handles?
Well, we've got the solution
that will let you step
right past them.
Sharks, I'm sure you've been
in a public restroom...
[ Pants zip ]
...washing your hands,
when the person next to you
has questionable hygiene habits.
[ Laughter ]
Take a look at this guy.
Greiner: Oh!
‐Oh, Kevin!
‐Oh, my gosh.
Let's see if he washes
his hands after ‐‐ Ugh! ‐‐
all of that.
‐[ Laughing ] Oh, gross.
‐Ew.
Disgusting.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Unbelievable.
Well, watch this.
♪♪
‐Ha!
‐Alright.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
I didn't see that coming,
I have to admit.
Thank goodness that's
a StepNpull‐equipped door,
so you'll worry no more.
StepNpull is a small device
that mounts on the bottom
of a commercial latchless door.
It offers the option of pulling
the door open with your foot
instead of grabbing
that germy door handle,
because we all know those
handle‐bacteria battlegrounds
are a common touch point
for all of us.
The StepNpull is a great option
on any latchless door
where hands‐free operation
is beneficial.
You can install it
in office buildings,
restaurant patio doors,
or clean‐room environments
for healthcare professionals.
Although germs have been
a big concern for many years,
the COVID‐19 pandemic
has triggered
hyper awareness
around this topic globally.
Sharks, which of you is ready
to fix this door‐handle dilemma
and take a step
into our world?
‐It's pretty clever.
‐Mike, it's a great innovation.
Is there not other products
that do the exact, same thing?
There are products
that are similar, yes.
We do have that patented,
though.
What's the patent?
What's different about
your product?
‐The teeth?
‐About ‐‐ Yes, it has the teeth.
Sewell:
It has ‐‐ just the design.
You step down
and pull the door open.
It's a low cost to manufacture
because of the design.
So tell us
about your business.
Yeah, so, this is
our 13th year in business.
Me and my two partners,
we had full‐time jobs,
and it was
a sideline business.
And the first five years
were fairly flat with sales.
We maybe sold $35,000.
And then, this year,
we've had a nice bump in sales.
I would imagine.
And we sold more in March
than we sold the whole time
we've been in business.
What'd you sell in March?
About a million seven.
What?!
‐Yeah.
‐Million seven?
‐You guys are killin' it, then.
‐$1 million?
‐Wow.
‐Of course.
Our year‐to‐date right now is,
we're approaching
$7 million in sales.
What?!
You what?
Wow.
How much do you sell these
to ‐‐ to wholesalers,
and what's it cost you
to make?
Well, retail is $29.95.
Our U. S. cost to manufacture
is between $8 and $9...
Uh‐huh.
...although we've just worked
with one of our manufacturers
in southwest Missouri and got
the price down to under $7.
Yeah, 'cause he's thrilled
to death, too, right...
Oh, yeah.
...'cause he's crushing it.
That was one of the best things
about it,
was the people we employed
during all this ‐‐
So ‐‐ So what percentage
of your business
is online
versus wholesale?
About 25% distributors
and 75% direct.
Damn!
Yeah, 75%.
You are killing it!
Yeah.
Yeah, our website sales
are the highest sales channel
with about over 30 ‐‐
probably 35% of our sales.
Mike, I mean, I always talk
about the American Dream.
You're living
the Inventor's Dream.
You know,
the most valuable asset
we can never own
is our time.
And you have an opportunity here
to make a choice ‐‐
take an investment
and hope you can just
take this back up
to millions of dollars a month,
or you can grow it
the way you always have
and it's worked for you,
and enjoy your time.
Not every business has to grow
to maximize sales,
because, again, the one asset
that's more valuable
than any dollar
you will ever earn
is your time and your ability
to enjoy that time.
So I'm out, but I'm telling you,
you don't need an offer.
Alright, thank you.
Herjavec:
Mike, you're killing it.
I think you'll continue,
but more at
the $300,000 level.
I think you've
hit a peak.
I don't want to buy in
at the peak.
For that reason,
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
I don't know how to value this
'cause of the peak COVID.
I think I can
add a lot of value maybe
in cutting
customer‐acquisition costs.
I don't know. I'm gonna do
the $300,000 for 10%.
I have a‐a level of interest.
Have you ever gone to IDA?
‐To where?
‐Ah‐ha!
[ Laughter ]
International
Door Association.
There's an
International Door Association?
There is something
for everything.
I have not.
So, I think that
I could take it there.
But I also have
a‐a fully automated factory
in New York
that I'm a partner in.
So I can reduce your cost,
probably,
and I can also
increase your sales.
Kevin wants 10%.
He brings nothing to it.
I'm gonna do it for 12%.
I don't agree with that.
$300,000 for 12%.
So, I'm gonna tell you
what I'm gonna do.
I see you have, like,
a commercial end,
and I see there's
a consumer end to this...
Mm‐hmm.
...because ‐‐
Why would people put this
in their homes, Lori?
No, I think people
will put this a lot of places.
I want to make you an offer,
and my plan would be to do
an infomercial with this.
I would do $300,000
for 5% equity.
I would want
50 cents back a unit.
And then once I've hit
$500,000,
then the royalty will drop
to 20 cents per.
I think
that's a garbage offer.
Yeah, I ‐‐
But I can help you
to blow this up
and get this into
every retailer, get it...
We all can do that.
...onto television,
get it digital.
I don't believe that.
Lori ‐‐ Lori,
I appreciate the offer.
I‐I struggle with
the infomercial because
it isn't a consumer product.
It isn't.
No, but it can be
a consumer product.
To get that ROI...
It's never gonna be that.
...outside of commercial,
I‐I don't know that
we would get that
because
businesses will buy.
Yes.
People in a home
will not.
No, no, I totally get that,
but what I'm saying to you is,
if we do it effectively,
right, so...
O'Leary:
Not a consumer product.
Lori ‐‐ Lori,
is your pitch over?
Greiner: ...I think
what happens is when ‐‐
Mike, Mike ‐‐ I have ‐‐
You got three offers.
What do you want to do?
Let me just finish.
I want to ‐‐
I mean, I want to ‐‐
You're being so rude.
You're saying the same thing.
Lori, we got your infomercial.
Your infomercial's done.
I'm just gonna keep going
just to make him crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
When you do that,
there's tons of people out there
that have businesses
that aren't gonna be
in that distribution channel
that you are already in.
I think I've heard enough.
So, I'm gonna give you
$300,000 for 8%.
Ooh, going down.
Ooh, I like that.
Um, Daymond,
can you do 6%?
I just went
from 12% to 8%.
Stick to your guns, Mike.
Stick to your guns.
And I'll help clear the air.
I'm gonna go out.
♪♪
Thank you.
Mike, down to two offers.
Yeah.
Cuban: Stick to
your guns, Mike.
♪♪
7%?
I'll do it at 7%.
♪♪
Daymond?
I know the value I bring.
I'll ‐‐ I'll do it at 8%.
You got a ‐‐ You got
a lot of margin there...
You don't need him, Mike.
...and I can bring down
those prices.
Beyond
the manufacturing help,
what's your vision for ‐‐
Well, I‐I told you about a trade
show you didn't even know about.
Right.
Well, that's true, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: I'll put more pressure
on if you want.
I'll do it at 6%.
Mike, what are you gonna do?
Now we're just begging, Kevin.
No, no, I'm just ‐‐ Look, you're
not gonna get what you want
'cause I'm gonna keep
squeezing.
Walk away. Walk away.
♪♪
Mike, Daymond's
$300,000 for 8%.
Kevin's $300,000.
He's at 6%.
Yeah, he's at 6%.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
‐Tough call.
‐Yeah.
♪♪
Kevin, let's do it.
Yes!
You made
the right decision, Mike.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Mike, you've built a great
business. Congratulations.
‐Congratulations.
I think you made
a really bad mistake,
but I wish you
all the best.
Alright, thank you.
And congratulations
on your success.
Good luck,
Mike.
‐Thank you.
‐Yes!
That's how you do a deal.
Sewell: A lot of businesses are
not making it through this time,
and we've been blessed
to have an opportunity
that does help businesses
open back up.
It helps keep their employees
and customers safe.
And for us to be in this
position is very humbling.
And we're ‐‐ we're so grateful
that, you know,
we have the opportunity.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a safer way
to receive deliveries.
♪♪
Oh, God.
Hi, Sharks, I'm Rebecca.
And I'm her husband, Eric.
We're from Arizona,
seeking $150,000
for 15% equity in...
DynoSafe!
People are ordering home
delivery for everything now ‐‐
clothing, electronics,
and, more importantly,
food, medication,
and other perishable items.
Yeah, the are.
Line, please.
[ Laughter ]
Line, please!
‐Thank you very much.
‐You can start over.
Yeah, feel free to
start over.
People are ordering home
delivery for everything now ‐‐
clothing, electronics,
and, more importantly,
medicine and food...
Eric: [ Whispering ]
"Other essential."
...and other
essential items.
[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
You know, we all need
essential items, so...
‐You can start over.
‐Essential, perishable items.
‐Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. Okay.
‐Yeah, take a breath.
‐Tell me the line.
‐"Other essential items."
"Other essential
perishable items."
And other essential
perishable items.
[ Mumbles ]
Okay.
And other essential
perishable items.
But how do we keep them safe,
secure, and fresh
until someone
can get them?
Introducing...
DynoSafe!
DynoSafe...
...the patented smart‐home
temperature‐controlled safe
that secures to the porch
and is essential
for contactless deliveries.
Here's how DynoSafe works.
Customers place an order
and assign a temperature to it
on our easy‐to‐use app.
And because it is
climate‐controlled,
it protects perishable items
like groceries,
takeout food,
and medication...
from the elements,
keeping them safe, secure,
and protected.
Whenever a simple, one‐click,
contactless delivery is made...
The DynoSafe app sends an alert
to the customer
that their delivery
has arrived
and they have sa‐‐ p‐‐
they have...
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
They ‐‐ They're happy
that it's protected
at the right
temperature.
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, the retailer
that rolls this out first
is going to own
the front porch
and push their competitors
to the curb.
Thanks to DynoSafe,
we can now safely deliver
our pitch...
To you.
to you.
[ Laughter ]
‐Good job.
‐Whoo!
‐Yay!
‐Rebecca, you did it!
How did you
come up with this?
I came up with this idea
because I owned a business
in the Dallas area,
and it was very successful.
Yeah!
What business?
It's a medi‐spa.
I came up with the idea
because as a business owner,
I had a patient
that asked me
to send them some things,
and I did,
and she claimed
she never received them.
So, we all dread
that phone call.
So, you pull another one
off your shelf
and you send that one
to them, too.
And it's really
eating into our profit.
And where are you now
at the stage of the business?
I started out with
a lot of research,
and I ‐‐ I got the patent
completely issued.
And so we've tested it
in Scottsdale and in Seattle.
‐I mean, how many homes?
‐How many physical homes?
Oh, okay, three.
Now, how did you engage
with the large online retailers?
There's one really,
really big one...
[ Laughs ]
...that everybody
orders from.
What happens with them?
We have had lots of
conversations
with those big people
and also grocery.
So, during this process,
what I learned was
grocery is the most desperate
to roll this out.
And I learned this
before coronavirus.
Coronavirus has just catapulted
everything forward
about three years.
Right.
After you tested
in only three homes...
Right.
...did you actually sell any?
No. So, this is a prototype.
That's all we have.
Our business model
is to license this out.
Our conversations with grocery
has revealed
that they desperately want
to roll this out
as part of
a subscription model.
Are you licensed to
any of them?
You're not selling this
to the consumer.
I haven't licensed
any yet.
I'm in conversations
with someone ‐‐
a‐a great big‐box retail
in the United States.
Let me tell you
the thing that's
the ‐‐ the most
special about this.
My patent protects
having the ability
to do one‐click unlock
and adjust the temperature
inside, the thermostat.
So you want to have
a subscription for it.
And I'm guessing it sends
a unique code.
The software sends
a unique code...
Right.
...to whoever's doing
the delivery.
That's right.
That's ‐‐
So there's not one code that
everybody uses all the time.
That's right.
I go to the DynoSafe app
and say, "Hey, yeah,
I'm gonna order
some groceries."
A random code ‐‐
one‐time‐use random code,
and I assign
a temperature to that.
So if I know I have
frozen items,
or if it's just produce,
I'll set that temperature,
and I'm done.
Here's my problem.
Okay.
If I went and talked to
my relationship guy at Amazon
and say, "Look,
theft is a huge problem.
What are you guys
doing about it?"
Now, am I to assume that
they're not working on that?
Yeah.
That Rebecca is
working on it?
Well, I've actually spoken
with them
and Walmart
and grocery executives.
And everybody's saying,
"We can't do it.
Only Rebecca can do it."
I‐I own the patent.
Yes.
And they cannot add
the temperature control
and smart together.
The combination is
really smart, right...
Yeah.
...because the temperature
control really is the key,
right, because there's
a dozen different ways
to do a smart unlock.
Yours having to do a code
is going be outdated
very quickly, right,
because it'll just be an app
that you walk up,
it says, "Oh, I recognize my app
via Bluetooth, RF,
whatever it may be."
Eric: Right.
And it sends a code to that app
that allows it to be unlocked.
And so because you have so far
to go in terms of catching up
with state‐of‐the‐art,
in terms of walk‐up unlocking,
that's a real challenge,
and it's going to be very
difficult for you to keep up.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. I am devastated to
hear that, honestly.
Why would a retailer take
such a big investment risk
to then lease it
to a customer
who may not be
a lifelong customer?
I just think it's gonna be
really challenging
to get the retailer
to take this in
and then issue it back out,
so I'm out.
And ‐‐ And I just ‐‐
I need to go back.
I think I was kind of,
you know ‐‐
obviously, I was
incredibly nervous.
Rebecca, I think
we understand ‐‐
No, no, no.
Let me ask you a question,
'cause I can see...
Yes.
...you're so passionate
about this...
Yeah, Lori.
...and I understand,
you know.
And I, obviously ‐‐
I know you're nervous
being here today.
Tell me, how much of your own
money did you put into this?
We're about $500,000 in.
‐Whoa!
‐$500,000?
‐And that's your own?
We're all in.
We're definitely all in, Lori.
No, there's ‐‐ there's
no joke.
Yeah.
I think what you did
is so smart.
I love that
you have a patent.
But what I don't love is,
is that I'm still a little
confused about all of this.
I just can't think of,
what are gonna be all the steps
that I'm going to do
to help you?
So, unfortunately,
for these reasons, I'm out.
♪♪
[ Exhales sharply ]
Rebecca,
is the $500,000 gone,
and what did
you spend it on?
So, it's on IP,
and it's also
on the engineering
and trade shows
and securing relationships.
I have a distributor
who has a current relationship
with a large‐box retailer
who they ‐‐ they ‐‐ they
already provide to them,
they distribute to them
the locker systems ‐‐
the temperature‐controlled
locker systems.
But, Rebecca,
it doesn't work that way.
If the distributor was truly
interested and you said to them,
"Look, I have this IP,
I have this patent,
but I don't have the money
to make the box,"
they would do it.
They would do it.
You're not a product company.
With all due respect,
you're not a software company.
To Mark's earlier point,
the ‐‐ the way you're
describing the software
and the locking working,
it's, like, 20 years ago.
I can tell you
about technology
that can secure a device
like that
just by somebody
walking up to it.
There's better ways
to do it.
But if the patent holds true
for the old way,
it would also hold true
for the new way.
Yes.
Robert, where are you
gonna do?
[ Sighs ]
Ye‐‐
My new‐world ways of doing this,
securing stuff,
makes me very interested
if the patent holds.
But I don't want to own
15% of it.
I want to own 51% of it.
Oy.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
but Robert is interested in
Eric and Rebecca's
temperature‐controlled
smart locker, DynoSafe.
But he wants a much bigger stake
in the company
than the 15% for $150,000
they came in offering.
I don't want to own
15% of it.
I want to own 51% of it.
Oy.
O'Leary: Let me take a different
stab at it, okay?
I also don't know
if your patent has merit.
I just don't.
But I'm gonna do the $150,000.
But I don't want control.
I'd like to get 40%,
'cause either this is binary...
Oh!
...it's either gonna work
or it isn't.
We're going to go
and license the technology.
That's my offer.
You have two offers.
You have to pick one.
What do you want to do?
Well...
♪♪
The thing is, Robert,
I can't give away
the majority of my business.
I mean, I've worked at this
for three years.
We've got everything
on the line,
and I've got to go
live with myself
when I walk out of here.
Um...
Here's ‐‐ Here's what
I'll do.
[ Sighs ]
You came in looking for
$150,000 for 15%.
I will give you
the $150,000
for...25%.
But...
we create
a board of directors.
Certainly.
I get more seats
than the two of you.
That's original.
If the three of us
get in a room...
Yeah.
...and there's two paths
in front of us...
Right.
...I need the ability
to say ‐‐
Robert, do you want me to be
one of those board seats?
For...
Yeah,
I'd love to have Mark.
Greiner: He wants to be
a controlling member.
I‐I‐I understand that.
So that's why he wants
more board seats.
Lori, thank you.
I would love that.
Thank you. Just to work with
the two of you ‐‐
So tell him you got a deal.
Is that a yes?
Yes, yes, yes!
Yes!
Virtual high five!
‐Ooh!
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you, Robert.
‐No. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Congrats.
Rebecca:
I'm super excited.
You know, at the end of the day,
I have two people
who are incredible
in the tech industry
and Robert, especially,
with security.
And, you know, I think
it's ‐‐ it's amazing,
and it's just gonna
propel us forward faster.
Creative, Rob.
I like it.
No, hey, Robert, it's either
Ring or it's nothing.
Yeah.
That's exactly
what I was thinking.
I‐I don't want to make
that mistake.
If the patent holds up,
which it sounds like it is,
'cause it could be huge.
This is a big problem.
If the patent ‐‐ If the
patent holds up for what
it suggests it can be...
It has big potential, yes.
...then it can be done.
♪♪
Narrator: Earlier this season,
we watched Michael Pan
make a deal with Mark Cuban
for his plant‐based
jerky company,
Pan's Mushroom Jerky.
It's now or never, Michael.
No, you can't do that.
Mark, you got to deal.
[ Cheering ]
Narrator:
Let's see what he's up to now.
Pan: We expected a sales bump
for our mushroom jerky,
but what happened
after airing on "Shark Tank"
completely blew away
our expectations.
The year before "Shark Tank,"
we did $750,000 in sales.
24 hours after our airing,
we did $650,000 in sales.
And within four days,
that number grew to $1 million
in online sales.
We immediately sold out, and in
a time when people needed jobs,
we went from a team of 10
to 30 employees.
We're working very hard
24 hours a day
in order to catch up
and meet demand.
For those of you who are still
waiting for your order,
I can't thank you enough
for your patience
and your support as we go
through these growing pains.
Cuban:
Never in my wildest dreams did
I think it would be that huge.
I knew it was gonna be big,
but, oh, my goodness.
Pan's Mushroom Jerky
is currently being sold
in over 800 locations
around the country.
In the next few months,
we plan to launch
in over 1,000 new locations
nationwide.
Having success with
a food product is difficult.
But when you have
a great product,
when you have a passionate,
smart entrepreneur,
you have that chance
to break through.
It's really easy for me
to see when concepts are good
from a business perspective.
It's harder to know
a great entrepreneur
when they first walk
on the carpet
in the short time we have.
But when you put the two
together and you click,
the results are astounding.
Pan: I've been working to make
mushroom jerky a thing
for a very long time.
I've been told no
over and over again.
Having the trust of Mark Cuban
to invest in our company
and also the response
from the orders from the show
is completely overwhelming
and tremendously satisfying.
For those of you who are wanting
to follow your dream,
I encourage you to never give up
and to keep pushing forward
and find a way
to make your dreams come true.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an affordable way
to make a trendy health food
at home.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Merrick Maxfield
from South Jordan, Utah.
For only 150K, you can own 7%
of a new technology
for something we all need.
Did you know humans can't live
without probiotics?
Probiotics are microorganisms
that live in our bodies
and help us in hundreds of ways,
including boosting
your immune system,
fighting diseases,
even improves sleep.
You can get probiotics
from healthy foods like yogurt
or even from pills.
But pills are super expensive.
Now, we have eight kids,
so I bought four cases
of yogurt.
Guess how long
those 32 yogurts lasted?
[ Laughing ]
Not even two days.
So we bought four yogurt makers,
but it took forever
and would fill the sink
with dishes.
So, Sharks,
that's when I decided
to stop the madness
and went to work.
[ Laughter ]
After 27 generations
of prototypes,
we ended up with the perfect,
inspired solution.
Introducing the Probiotic Maker.
Cuban: Whoa!
[ Greiner chuckles ]
So, simply add a starter packet
with 11 types of probiotic seeds
to a bottle of milk
or milk alternative.
♪♪
Then slide on
the Probiotic Maker...
[ Laughter ]
...and plug it in overnight.
That's it.
‐That's it?
‐I don't understand.
It's as easy
as making eight kids.
That's it!
[ Laughter ]
That's not easy,
I'll tell you.
My wife will tell you.
[ Laughter ]
So, here's some probiotics that
have been cultured and cooled.
So, let's go ahead
and make a giant parfait here.
You can see
the thickened probiotics.
‐Wow.
‐Add the ‐‐
you got some granola,
you can add some fresh berries.
Now let's flavor
an entire bottle
with some fresh strawberries.
Ooh.
It is so good.
Don't spill it.
Give it
a little shake there.
So ‐‐ Aah!
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Alright.
I'm making more mess
than my kids.
So, best part is
you control the sugar,
the fat, the milk type,
the flavorings
to make yogurt, kefir,
smoothies.
Just one batch is equivalent
to hundreds of pills
and can save over 100 pieces
of plastic and garbage
from polluting our oceans
and landfills.
Wow.
‐One batch.
‐Wow.
So, who wants a taste of
the soon‐to‐be‐most‐successful
"Shark Tank" product ever?
[ Laughter ]
I‐I‐I got a que‐‐
Is this safe?
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah.
Cuban:
You're gonna find out.
It is 11 types
of fresh probiotics.
So if you start
with the green one,
that one is made from
a high‐protein
almond and cashew
milk alternative.
Oh, it tastes good.
Oh, it's really good.
Yeah.
Okay.
No, it's ‐‐ it's like
desirably good.
Like, I want to go buy it.
Very good.
‐"E" is good.
‐Yeah, it's like cream.
Now try "B."
"B" is my personal favorite.
It has a little sugar
or sweetening in it.
Yeah, I‐I flavored these.
[ Smacks lips ] That's yogurt‐y.
That's very yogurt‐y.
Ugh!
Are you worried at all
about
somebody not doing
the process correctly,
tainting the milk,
and poisoning themselves?
Is there any risk of that?
So, as long
as you start with
a fresh,
unopened bottle of milk
that's been purified,
you're ‐‐
there's not the bad seeds
in there.
O'Leary: So you're not worried
about that?
Merrick, all you're doing
is you're heating ‐‐
This is just really
a heat pad?
Yes. It does it all
magically overnight.
It's all automatic.
And this targets
body temperature.
I had the inspiration ‐‐
If you want probiotics to thrive
at body temperature,
then why not grow it
in the body temperature?
Why has no one
thought of this before?
What are your strains
of probiotic in here?
So, this, um...
Yeah, the lactose ‐‐
the most common, uh...
lactobacillus, "bifidobim,"
and, uh, "rhasmosus,"
"acidmophilus," so...
Listen,
I gotta tell you ‐‐
When you sell something
that people ingest,
it is really important
to know
and have
on your packaging...
Yep.
...because every probiotic
will tell you,
what are the exact
probiotics in it...
The exact probiotics.
Well ‐‐
...the names of them.
Herjavec: Merrick,
I may not know
the names
of all the strains...
Oh, yeah.
...but I do know the name of,
what are your sales?
[ Laughs ]
Okay, so in 2018,
our sales were
about $22,000.
How much?
‐$22,000.
$22,000.
And then
last year's sales
increased by, like,
almost 350%...
To what?
...to about $76,000.
And then ‐‐
How are you worth
$2.5 million?
Hold on.
And then?
We went to the ‐‐ the
International Housewares Show.
There, we were told that we
needed to get UL certification.
Got it.
And so we lost
most of last year
working through
the UL certification process.
And your sales
this year?
And our sales this year ‐‐
like $18,000.
What?
Because ‐‐
Oh, wow!
So, what it is ‐‐
Okay, let's talk about
anger management.
I have been working
very hard this year,
as you may know,
on anger management.
You came in here...
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
He's failed today.
...at $2.5 million valuation
with $18,000 in sales.
Do you see anything wrong
with that at all?
That is ‐‐ during the COVID,
there's been $18,000.
Lifetime sales is
about $150,000.
I get it, but the trajectory
of sales is this.
This is not good.
This is good.
Not good. Good.
Yeah.
Merrick, what does
one of these cost?
‐Yeah.
‐Okay.
The Probiotic Maker sells
for $99.95 MSRP.
$99 for this?
Yeah.
Right now, it's just under
$20 to make them.
John:
I think it's ‐‐ it's ‐‐
With me, I think that
you have a huge market
because I'm a ‐‐
I'm a ‐‐ you know,
someone who takes the stuff.
But I don't know
enough about science.
I'll be very honest.
I don't know.
And Lori and some
of the other Sharks
really know, like, FDA approval
and stuff like that.
So I just don't know
if it's worth the risk for me.
So I'm out.
Okay, sorry to hear that.
I do think that this is
really interesting,
because I'm a probiotic taker,
believer.
They tasted great.
The only problem for me is I
just don't see anything on this
that gives me all the already
tried‐and‐true safety testing
and things
that I would want to see
to say,
"Okay, now I feel safe."
Herjavec: Is that
your only problem?
This is all...
It truly is
my only problem.
...FDA‐certified.
You're not there yet
for me
to feel comfortable with it
as an investor...
So, we can put whatever...
...regardless of
the valuation.
So I'm sorry.
I'm out.
...whatever you would like.
Alright,
I'm sorry to hear that.
I'm sorry.
O'Leary: Why in the world
would you want to
waste your time with this?
The mountain you have to climb
to tell consumers
how to use this thing,
convince them to try it,
even educate people around
the benefits of probiotics ‐‐
that's crazy.
Like, why would you
even attempt to do that?
I don't even want to talk about
the $2.5 million valuation.
You know that was a mistake.
This is a horrific idea
and, in some ways, evil.
That bad. That bad.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Oh, come on.
‐Alright.
‐I think there's evil.
Cuban: What are you
gonna do, Kevin?
Oh.
Oh, I'm out.
Merrick, look, I don't see
the $2.5 million valuation.
I'm out.
The concept is
really good, right?
You just aren't
quite there yet.
I mean,
as smart as you are, right ‐‐
I am having people
from a hospital of ‐‐
a liver doctor called me,
a gastroenterologist.
Merrick, Merrick,
hold on, hold on.
What I'm gonna tell you is,
functionality‐wise,
I understand completely,
and everything you're saying
rings true
and makes perfect sense,
right?
But the hard part
is the marketing side, right?
Yes.
Because you're having
challenges here.
There's just
too many things
that I'm uncertain about
from the marketing side.
We could ‐‐
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
We could do a contingency
on whatever ‐‐
You're just early.
If you didn't come in here
saying this was worth
$2.5 million,
you would have
gotten a deal.
I just had no idea.
I know why you said
$2.5 million.
You got eight kids.
So make me an offer.
I'm sorry, Merrick.
You're not quite there yet.
Alright,
so everybody's out?
‐Everyone's out.
‐Yes. Good luck.
‐Good luck, Merrick.
‐Good luck.
Thank you.
Greiner: Good luck, Merrick.
It tasted good.
Oh.
I‐I just can't fathom why
they wouldn't want
to take a chance
on this tremendous opportunity.
It's the lowest‐cost probiotics,
the most convenient,
the best tasting,
and you can save the planet
at the same time.
What ‐‐ What more do they want?
What more do the Sharks want?
He was doing
$18,000 in sales.
Oh!
He said the company was
worth $2.5 million.
I really do think that he has
a good idea here, but ‐‐
‐Kevin, plug it in.
‐Lori, Lori, Lori, Lori.
[ Laughs ]
I'm gonna go plug my head in,
okay?
‐Please do.
‐That was the worst.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is protection
for an important part
of modern life.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Kevin Conway,
and I'm from Charlotte,
North Carolina.
And I'm Josh Inglis
from Atlanta, Georgia.
We're here seeking
$500,000
for 10% of our company,
PHOOZY.
Now, that may sound
expensive,
but you know
what's really expensive?
Our phones, our laptops,
and our tablets,
especially when you have to
replace them because of damage.
Just leaving your phone
out in the sun
can cause
permanent battery damage.
Drop it in the lake?
It's sunk.
And I could've taken a selfie
on that double black diamond
if my phone hadn't died.
Sure, dude.
"Double black diamond."
No, I swear.
My phone died
from the cold.
Anyway, that's why
we invented PHOOZY.
PHOOZY is the world's
first thermal capsule
to protect
your expensive devices
from overheating
in the sun,
extend battery life in the cold,
float in water,
and provide military‐grade
drop protection.
Did we mention that it's made
from space‐suit technology?
It's like a space suit
for your phone, literally.
But don't just
take our word for it.
Sharks,
we want you to put
our patented technology
to the test.
Daymond, can we invite you up
to the climate‐testing lab?
‐Yeah.
‐Okay.
Get in the suit, Daymond.
Get in the suit.
‐Let's go.
‐Send him to outer space.
We have a lab coat for you,
along with safety glasses.
Sharks, we'll be using
this thermal‐imaging camera
so that you can see
the hot and cold temperatures
through each
of the simulations.
[ Light laughter ]
So, what we've done is we've
placed an unprotected device
and a phone inside of
the PHOOZY thermal capsule
for each
of your simulations.
The first one is gonna be
the extreme heat
of the solar simulation.
So go ahead and touch the
unprotected device right there.
It's pretty hot.
John:
Yeah, it's really hot.
I don't even know if
this phone probably would work.
Now pick this up?
‐Sure.
‐Pick up the PHOOZY.
Uh‐huh.
And then you can open it up
with those tabs on top
and remove the device,
and you can feel
the temperature difference.
Wow. It's almost ‐‐
it's almost cool.
You guys can actually see
right there.
That is the phone that was
inside of the PHOOZY,
and then that phone...
Yeah, and this bag
is not hot.
...right there is
well over 100 degrees.
‐This protector is not hot.
‐Not hot at all.
‐Okay.
‐Correct.
So, now your next mission is
going to be to experience
the freeze
of the Arctic simulation.
Okay.
You can carefully touch
that unprotected device
because that is
negative‐50‐degree dry ice.
Whoa!
Be careful there.
It's very, very cold.
But you can see
the temperature there.
Now go ahead and pick up
the PHOOZY, and same thing.
Remove the device.
Let's check the temperature
of that device.
This is cold, though.
Yep, you can see
the difference there ‐‐
about 65 degrees
of that device...
Uh‐huh.
...but it's still
gonna work...
Okay.
...where the other device
is gonna be
completely frozen
and dead.
You see
the temperature there ‐‐
it's going greater
than negative 40.
Okay.
‐Wow.
‐Be careful.
So, Daymond,
your final simulation
is gonna be what we call
our "Ohhh No!" simulation.
Okay.
So that PHOOZY there
has a phone inside the blue one.
Go ahead and drop it in.
‐Drop the whole one in?
‐Yes, sir.
Drop the whole thing in.
As you can see,
our sink‐proof technology
keeps your device
at the surface of the water
so you can quickly
retrieve it.
Okay, I got it.
‐Yeah.
‐Very cool.
So, thank you, Daymond.
Good job, Daymond.
Thank you.
It was nothing.
Tell us about you guys.
So, for the past
25 years,
I've been a professional
race car driver,
having raced at
the highest levels
of motorsports in America.
I raced in
the NASCAR Cup Series.
You raced the NASCAR Cup?
I did.
I was a Rookie of the Year
in 2010
and transitioned to racing
sports cars with Lamborghini.
Inglis:
And prior to PHOOZY,
I spent over 15 years
as an executive
at one of the largest
home‐improvement retailers,
helping grow online revenue
from $100 million
to over $5 billion
in 2017.
‐Wow.
‐Wow. How did you guys ‐‐
How did you get together
to start the company?
We've been great friends
for over 20 years.
We're always talking about
business ideas.
But finally, in 2016, Kevin came
to me with this great idea,
and, honestly, I was ready
for a ‐‐ ready for change.
I know this space
from a bunch of products
over the years
on "Shark Tank,"
and there are many, many, many,
many case companies...
Sure.
...and are you telling me
there isn't one other
that gives me protection
against heat and cold
and drop protection?
I'm having a real hard time
believing that.
Sure. There is not.
In fact, we have
an issued utility patent
around
our thermal technology
and also the drop and the float
components of our product.
Is there even a demand
for this?
In the 36 months
since launch,
we've done $1.9 million
in sales.
‐Hello!
‐Okay.
We did $700,000
in sales last year.
This year, we'll be
at $1.5 million.
We're projected to be
at $4.5 million next year.
Is this through retail?
It's almost all
direct‐to‐consumer.
Now, that's great.
That's impressive.
That's very impressive.
What will you
make on that?
25%.
Why does one cost?
Our blended gross margin
is 88%.
Cuban:
That's your gross margin?
‐Yes.
Damn!
Landed cost is anywhere
from $3 to $15.
Retail is anywhere
from $30 to $70.
This one that's silver that has
an iPhone in it ‐‐
Is this the lowest...?
It is.
That's the entry point.
That is our entry point.
That is just under $3,
and that sells for $29.99.
The black one ‐‐
that cost is about $3.85.
That product retails
for $34.99.
The silver one there
is just under $5,
and that retails for $50.
You guys are my heroes.
Oh, my God.
Herjavec: Have you raised
a lot of money,
and how much money
have you put in?
Sure. So, we have not
raised any money.
We have bootstrapped
this entire thing.
Josh and I have put in
$85,000.
We've been profitable
every quarter since launch.
[ Clapping ]
‐Wow.
And we've just
slugged it out.
I was not expecting
that answer.
You guys, look,
the product's phenomenal.
Your accomplishments
are phenomenal.
I'm not the rugged
outdoors type, you know?
It's just not my scene, so
it would be really hard for me
to support you
promotionally.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations.
What you've been able
to accomplish so quickly
is phenomenal.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
So what do you need
my $500,000 for?
So, the biggest thing for us
is scaling our team
to add a few key positions,
because it's just Josh and I.
It's really hard for us
to keep up
and ‐‐ and to support
that growth.
If I give you $500,000
and I participate
in 10% distributions,
it's gonna take me 10 years
to get my money back?
Or how fast do you think
you're gonna grow?
It should be more like
three to four years
to get your money back.
Guys, let ‐‐ let me put it
this way ‐‐
Rather than fight
about the equity here,
because I‐I actually think
you're overvalued a little bit,
I would do the deal this way.
I'd give you the $500,000
for 4% equity,
and I'd want a dollar
a unit,
'cause your margins
are so crazy high,
until I get back
a $1.5 million,
and then the royalty
goes away forever.
But, I mean, I think you guys
are fantastic operators.
What do you say, guys?
Would you do that royalty
till you get $1 million back?
I'd do it $1.2 million.
Can we go to $1 million?
Can we make it $1 million?
I'd do that deal.
I'd do the deal.
Now you got some action going,
don't you?
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out,
and there's a bidding war over
Kevin and Josh's
device‐protection company,
PHOOZY.
Can we go to $1 million?
Can we make it $1 million?
I'd do that deal.
I'd do the deal.
Now you got some action going,
don't you?
I will do the $500,000
for the 4%
until I get
the $500,000 back.
Same royalty.
Okay.
Let me tell you
what I think of this, okay?
You blow me away at the job
that you did by yourselves
in design,
manufacturing, marketing.
So what's your offer?
$500,000, 4% equity,
a dollar per unit
to $1 million,
and then the royalty
will go away.
I'll stick it
to $500,000.
Guys, this is ‐‐
you are great operators.
This is an operations
business.
I love the B2B play.
That's where I can help you.
You realize you're just getting
your capital back, Robert.
More is great.
You don't need to do that.
Yes, you do,
because what you don't know
is what can get you
in trouble.
Absolutely.
So you need experience,
and you need someone
that can help you
from falling into some pitfalls.
Would you guys
want to work together?
I would partner with Robert
if we each got 4% equity.
Yeah.
At the $500,000 royalty?
Will you match
Robert's deal on that,
till you get your money back
and you each get 4%?
Come on, Lori.
What's $500,000?
I mean, this is
an operations thing,
Let's just get our money back.
I think that's super fair.
My feeling is
if you go $1.50
royalty per,
then I'm good
with that deal.
You have a great margin.
It's not gonna matter to you...
Just to put pressure...
...but it's gonna matter to me.
...let me modify my offer,
just to squeeze
their heads a bit.
I want the royalty
to be $1.50.
Then tell them
what the offer is.
Okay.
I'll do this deal ‐‐
$500,000 for 2.5%,
and I'd want $1 a unit
until I get $1 million back.
Why give up 8%
if you really believe
in the equity?
Why would you give up
8% equity
and only get $500,000?
Why would you do that?
That's a great deal, Lori.
They get the both of us.
Because you get
the both of us,
and think about it.
They're not that valuable.
I mean, that makes
no sense to me.
But you guys think
about it.
That is not
an economic decision.
Think how much faster
you're gonna grow.
You're gonna dominate
the market with these.
Yeah.
She's right.
♪♪
Let's do it.
‐Whoo!
‐Whoa‐ho!
Cuban: Congratulations, guys.
Well done.
Ahhhhh!
Yeah, whatever Robert
just did.
‐Lori!
‐[ Laughs ]
Both: Whoo!
Robert, I gave up my seat at
Le Mans to be here this weekend,
so [laughs] that's how much ‐‐
how important this is.
Oh, that's ‐‐
You are all in,
'cause I don't know if
I would have done that. Wow.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Congrats. Well done.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
♪♪
Inglis: Robert and Lori
were very passionate
about our product,
and they were such big fans
of Kevin and I,
we had to do
the deal with them.
They even gave us a higher
valuation than we came in with.
We've seen a lot of episodes
of "Shark Tank"
where that was not the case,
so we're very grateful.
O'Leary:
That's the stupidest deal
I've ever seen you do
on "Shark Tank."
That's an unbelievably
dumb deal.
The thing that you didn't
really focus on
or think about
is licensing.
The man is loaded
with patents.
It doesn't matter, Lori.
‐Yes.
‐Yes!
This product is so amazing.
You have no upside
on your capital
and only equity risk.
They are the Sharks,
and you are the tin foil.
N‐N‐No!
No!
Kevin, screw you.
Learn, grasshopper.
Listen to the Shark
and learn.
Dumbest deal
I've ever seen.
♪♪